sie alle wollen auf und davon
familie tobler aus dem thurgau sucht das
große abenteuer in australien
lenny und hansjörg eger aus dem aargau
bauen in thailand eine seniorenresidenz
familie tänzer aus dem kanton bern
träumt von einem besseren leben und wagt
den neuanfang in florida wiedersehen mit
hermann schönbächler
der bieler förster und seine familie
haben das glück tief im kanadischen wald
gefunden
[Musik]
große überraschung in australien nach
nur fünf monaten in ihrem mietshaus
zielen rolf dobler und seine familie
schon wieder aus sie haben sich einen
lang gehegten traum erfüllt und eine
kleine farm mitten im busch gekauft weil
rolf dobler nicht nur geld ausgeben kann
sondern möglichst bald wieder welches
verdienen muss präsentierte er letzte
woche seine geschäftsidee er will
feuerfeste schweizer bodenbeläge
importieren in thailand über hansjörg
eger seine rede für die eröffnungsfeier
der seniorenresidenz und rührte seine
frau leni zu tränen
in kanada sorgte der erste schnee für
viel arbeit und viel freude in florida
wollte sich familie tänzer vom stress
der ersten wochen in der neuen heimat
sie machten einen ausflug in die
everglades
[Musik]
rolf dobler fährt mit dem möbel anhänger
zur farm hinaus der vor kurzem gekauft
hat sie liegt mitten im australischen
busch 40 kilometer weit weg von ihrem
bisherigen zuhause nyse alu ist fahrer
hätte das genau da wo noch sucht yb
bisher vize weg und glich mit einem
ganzen bus schönsten nicht falls moody's
herab sich jetzt direkt vom staat
derweil heißt er du und hat gerade
einmal 20 einwohner täglich
das neue zuhause der thurgauer
auswanderer
es ist eine typische australische
hobbyfahrer mit verschiedenen gebäuden
und unglaublichen 23.000 quadratmeter
land in den letzten wochen wohnten die
auswanderer noch im sheraton arbeiteten
aber fast täglich hier draußen um das
haus auf vordermann zu bringen
[Musik]
darum werden ihn viele beneiden weil das
haupthaus nur zwei schlafzimmer hat wird
der 15-jährige kevin künftig in seinem
eigenen haus schlafen beide häuschen und
das riesige grundstück haben gerade
einmal 230 1000 franken gekostet
die wunderschöne natur gibt es kostenlos
dazu
[Musik]
bevor die auswanderer ihre erste nacht
im neuen heim verbringen können gibt es
noch viel zu tun
[Musik]
insgesamt sitzen in der schweiz hatte
kevin ein kinderzimmer hier hatte soeben
sein eigenes kleines haus eingerichtet
stolz präsentiert da ist seine mutter
eigenen koch hat kevin das haus für sich
allein
seine eltern wollen aber möglichst bald
ein zimmer für sohn dylan anbauen
der zehnjährige schläft vorerst noch im
haus bei den eltern
[Musik]
in kanada hat der astronomische winter
noch nicht begonnen
und doch liegen bereits 70 cm schnee
drews schönbächler und sein vater
hermann haben alle hände voll zu tun
[Applaus]
[Musik]
in kanada sind die lebenshaltungskosten
tief der bieler auswanderer kann seine
familie auch mit einem teilzeitpensum
bestens ernähren
zeit zum faulenzen hatte aber nicht erst
recht nicht wenn er wieder einmal ohne
schneeketten mit dem traktor unterwegs
ist und er hätte strom so jäh zerstört
und probierens wenn die rabiat
garchinger weiß nicht 13
das geht das ganz schlimm
als gurken mein bestes erschuf kalt ziel
frauchen stelle
[Applaus]
macht
was in den chefetagen der wirtschaft
gilt trifft auch in der kanadischen
wildnis zu hinter jedem erfolgreichen
mann steht eine starke frau
das ist außen- und dann verteilt
[Musik]
bei dennis und cloud dancer hat sich in
den letzten wochen viel getan
nachdem sie sich privat eingerichtet
haben kümmern sie sich ums geschäft sie
sind unterwegs zu ihrem ferienhaus dass
sie für die ersten gäste herrichten
müssen um ein haar hätte kleid dancer
einen hund überfahren
[Musik]
die auswanderer wollen ihr geld künftig
als vermieter verdienen
neben diesem ferienhaus haben sie noch
eine wohnanlage mit sechs appartements
gekauft
[Applaus]
nur schlittschuh dass neben haben
seit ihrer auswanderung sind da nicht so
ein kleid tänzer nicht nur privat ein
paar
als vermieter diverser liegenschaften
sind sie auch beruflich ein team
[Musik]
neben kleinen dorf nachbarn gibt es an
diesem morgen nur ein thema die
eröffnung der seniorenresidenz von anni
und hans jörg eder
kein wunder die auswanderer haben in den
letzten nächten kaum geschlafen
[Musik]
für die woz
[Gelächter]
springer blumenform großer kreis von
heute wer hat heute haben wir große park
und dann wird er wies zudem bringe und
weil es gibt immer glück bringen wir
auch essen weil sich lange jäger und das
essen für den großen geist kümmert hat
ihr mann hans jörg seinen ersten einsatz
als ministrant er assistiert eine mensch
der die humba los der residenz 7
[Musik]
drei der insgesamt zehn bungalows sind
bereits fix vermietet
mädels vom 4
die segnung der bungalows hat lang jäger
verpasst das nächste highlight wie sie
sich aber auf keinen fall entgehen
lassen
frauke mit
das ist telefon kaum noch 2 ich bin sehr
wie immer nun für die eröffnungsfeier
haben sie drei elefanten gebucht
[Musik]
nach dem verheerenden sturm hat hermann
schönbächler genügend brennholz für die
nächsten acht jahre gehabt das leben in
der abgeschiedenheit ist hart und
anstrengend aber es ist das leben das
christina und hermann schönbächler immer
gesucht haben dort womöglich bewohner
momentan das eben sehr gut das haut
absolut was mir nicht gesprochen
ja mit strom oder gas strom oder stimmt
stimmt da was ist sonst immer kurz um 4
uhr tony jaa für dienst möglichkeiten
die sie diese absolut thomas ich gut als
motto vor heute
die lebenshaltungskosten in kanada sind
mit rund 30000 franken viel tiefer als
in der schweiz
hermann schönbächler muss nur 60 tage
pro jahr als förster geld verdienen um
seine familie ernähren zu können
der wahre luxus ist sowieso unbezahlbar
die freiheit mitten in der natur zu tun
und zu lassen was einem gefällt
[Musik]
für die drei kinder hat das einsiedler
leben aber auch nachteile schule vereine
und spielkameraden sind nur mit dem auto
erreichbar
[Musik]
muss sich in zukunft das unkomplizierte
wird sie man kinder größer sehen wir
schon sie sportart geschäftemacher zum
teuersten organisiert war und auf dem
globus sind und bei und einfach nach der
schule vor ort aber darum sich
organisieren mit seiner extra vor oder
sie haben mit der stadt nach
übernachtungsmöglichkeiten ich bin nicht
aus
[Musik]
der 15-jährige kevin hat die erste nacht
in seinem haus gut überstanden
[Musik]
mit der hobby form geht nicht nur kevins
traum in erfüllung
vater rolf will mit seinem teppichhandel
das nötige geld für den lebensunterhalt
verdienen
ansonsten aber möglichst viel zeit mit
der familie verbringen mutter immer will
einen gemüsegarten anlegen und lernen
wie man siegen merkt um eigenen käse
herzustellen
thelen und kevin wissen nicht einmal die
schule wechseln
der schulbus holt sie selbst dem
abgelegenen organisieren wie lebe und
hob sie sind wenn wir zusätzlich sehen
da abläuft sind so einfach sie die
nächsten zwei jahre bei 2 mose findet
münsterfeld erleben oder strahlen wenn
man sich vorstellt bevor kevin in die
schule muss absolviert er seine
lieblings lektion der 15-jährige kann
bereits in einem jahr mit gewissen
auflagen die australische fahrprüfung
absolvieren
[Musik]
mit seinem vater macht er eine
spritztour auf dem grundstück
[Musik]
platz genug haben sie das grundstück ist
riesig und nachbarn die man stören
könnte gibt es nicht
wärst du happy von der größe her ist
genau wie das vorgestellte buch schland
warum reden wir wollen nicht einfach nur
flache schuhe lässig also mir ein club
für mega geplant
[Musik]
mit dem geld aus dem hausverkauf in der
schweiz konnte kleid dancer in florida
nebst ihrem einfamilienhaus noch weitere
immobilien kaufen
der ehemalige autoverkäufer ist
unterwegs um mieten einzutreiben
[Musik]
mitten in cape coral hat er an bester
lage eine anlage mit sechs bewohnten
appartements gekauft die berner
auswanderer werden ihr geld künftig als
vermieter verdienen wie viel er für die
palm brice appartements bezahlen musste
will greift tänzer nicht verraten nur so
viel die gepflegte anlage sei ein
schnäppchen gewesen
fixed amerikaner informiert und ist
eigentlich dass sie dem haus eines
grundeinkommens pro monat
die sechs wohnungen bringen monatlich
rund 4000 franken mieteinnahmen hier
wohnen vor allem berufstätige die im
nahen fort myers arbeiten
[Musik]
unglaublich was da ist es gut wenn wir
davon schweiz grund und aufbaukurse
fronline beinkleid und hier hat die bank
das auf die kontakt und schon altkleider
insel zur nächsten termin
doch im gegensatz zu seinem früheren job
als geschäftsführer einer großen auto
garage in der schweiz ist dieser stress
freiwillig
seine frau denise wartet bereits vor dem
ferienhaus auf ihn
die beiden haben es mit viel freude nach
ihrem geschmack eingerichtet
hallo die ersten zahlenden gäste des
ferienhauses sind flüchtige bekannte von
drei tänzer heute dürften es zehn buches
problem
die drohungen ging zwar im australien
steht wieder deuce
welcome drink und es ist noch nicht
lange her da machten tunis und clyde
tänzer selbst ferien in cape coral jetzt
zeigen sie ihren ersten mietern die
schönheiten ihrer neuen heimat
[Musik]
die polizisten stehen stramm die
uniformen sind frisch gebügelt zur
eröffnungsfeier seiner seniorenresidenz
erwartet hansjörg eger aus bangkok
ja klar wenn ich dafür ist das ist
einmalig so laut ist oder dass sie
erstens sowie fahr zur pause meinte
heute morgen 16 es ist haben sich die
los daheim dass sie dann zu niedrig oder
das natürlich schon her dass es auch die
mir nimmt und sie sagen herr stolz
und ausgerechnet als ich gerade eine der
glücks fahnen in einem baum verheddert
hat trifft die schweizer botschafterin
christine schraner burgener 1
da war die partie
[Musik]
zuerst begrüßt hansjörg eger die mutter
der botschafterin frauen aus dem dorf
und die angestellten der residenz stehen
spanier landesmutter begrüßt den gast
traditionell mit seinen stoff und auch
das gehört zur tradition unter der
anleitung eines buddhistischen mönchs
beten alle gemeinsam verbunden durch
einen faden
alte frauen aus dem dorf schenken den
gästen an münchen das bringt glück
lothar j und bin zufrieden
bodenständiger geht es dann beim
festessen zu und her
daniela serviert schnitzel pommes frites
[Musik]
zum ersten mal herrscht hochbetrieb im
neuen restaurant die mieterinnen der
seniorenresidenz und die geladenen gäste
lassen sich verwöhnen
[Musik]
in kanada verwandelt hermann
schönbächler den vorplatz seines hauses
in ein eisfeld
der eintritt ist gratis vergnügen
unbezahlbar
sorry
[Musik]
gabi herrmann zeigt wie es gibt ja damit
durch die zum vortrag so hermann
schönbächler hat in der schweiz mehr
geld verdient reich geworden ist die
familie aber erst hier war ich an
lebensqualität
oder wie es der bieler förster ausdrückt
in kanada konnten sie ihre bestimmung
zugeführt werden
[Applaus]
für die szene vor einem monat hat die
ganze jugend jahren träumten übergänge
zwischen er wird heute zwar dafür dass
man noch alle kreisfreien städten sowie
auf die nach drei jahren muss der
vorstellung
[Applaus]
christine und hermann schönbächler
gehöre nicht zu jenen auswanderern die
ihre heimat aus frust und
unzufriedenheit verlassen haben
sie wussten einfach immer hoch im norden
erwartet ihr ganz persönliches paradies
auf sie hier gehören sie hin
[Musik]
dennis tänzers paradies sind flohmärkte
die hier in amerika etwas unromantisch
garrett sales heißen die bündnerin macht
kalligraphie und restauriert alte möbel
sie träumt davon ihr kunsthandwerk in
einem eigenen kleinen laden verkaufen zu
können
[Musik]
doch zuerst muss das haus fertig
eingerichtet werden der nicht tänzer
sucht eine sitzgruppe für die heimische
terrasse
drin ist und so ruft ihren mann an heyo
k sitzgruppe verlustzone fliegen aber
auch nicht schlecht also rasch wie
möglich alle sich 250
ja ja ja so schneller schneller walker
darum ist es perfekt
ich denke so martin joey
aber das beispiel bei der mode
dann und
oberflächlicher kredit wird mir gefällt
das alles einfach gründlichkeit und
[Musik]
clyde tänzer hatte anscheinend doch den
richtigen riecher als er seine frauen
seine töchter überzeugte nach florida
auszuwandern
die familie fühlt sich nach einigen
startschwierigkeiten pudelwohl hier
larissa und franca haben sich in der
schule bestens eingelebt und mutter
janis tänzer hat den lockeren lebensstil
für sich entdeckt kley dancer genießt
mit seiner frau den lauen sommerabend
auf der neuen sitzgruppe die station ist
markus im fußball und im augenbereich
ort ist natürlich niemand wird also die
dekoration geschafft eigentlich
was macht spaß aber ich hoffe ich das
richtig das wichtigste
familienunternehmen
[Musik]
noch in diesem monat blieben ich will
heute mit so viel engagement und hätte
ballack mit chelsea und etwas machen
dann hätte das genossen hatte immer das
gefühl klarer denken die nachbarin
gesehen das mich auf die stadt und der
problem hätte überhaupt will
da machen alle doch die nehmen sich
extrem zählt sie zur familie
vielen hilft seinem vater bei der
renovation des hühnerstalls davon hat
rolf dobler geträumt als er die
verkaufte mit seinen kindern täglich
kleine abenteuer erleben
auch das geschäft mit den bodenbelägen
wieder von zu hause aus betreiben
selbst ein kolibri baumaterial in seinem
beruf besser geschlagen
[Musik]
die thurgauer haben den ehrgeiz im
australischen busch weitgehend als
selbstversorger leben zu können
den anfang machen fünf hühner noch haben
sie keine erfahrung als farmer buch dank
hilfsbereite nachbarn und im internet
lernen sie täglich dazu ja jetzt wohl so
der sv geislitz viele fans aber ganz
oben befindet wenn irgendwo besuchs
geschrieben ist oder die derzeitige lage
immer noch liege oder zuschläge ja aber
jetzt wo es mit deiner firma ga
[Musik]
die hühner in australien sind auf jeden
fall genügsamer als die elefanten in
thailand während die dickhäuter al anis
vorgarten fressen sucht hansjörg eger
seine frau sie hat den hausschlüssel und
er will sich unbedingt noch fein machen
für den großen festumzug nicht getragen
[Musik]
[Applaus]
stolz führt lange jäger die prächtigen
parade an die von ihrem wohnhaus zur
seniorenresidenz führt
[Musik]
frohe botschaft ja so dass olaf egal mit
wer kann schon von sich sagen dass er
seinen betrieb mit einer tanzenden
diplomatin eröffnet hat
und dann ist es soweit die schweizer
botschafterin enthüllt das
eingangsportal der seniorenresidenz
[Musik]
[Applaus]
sehr geehrte frau botschafterin sehr
geehrte gäste aus nah und fern
es freut mich außerordentlich solide
jahres begrüßen dürfen
lange raus möchte ich mich ganz herzlich
bedanken
ich werde hier raus
nach acht monaten bauzeit ist die
seniorenresidenz offiziell eröffnet
krane frage ja und und und kritik an mir
ja aber dann meist nicht mit
also ich glaube meine jungs voll mit der
bungalow vechta - oder 29 auf dur
vermietet aber da spielen und ich glaube
das schafft
[Musik]
ihre liebe war stärker als alle sorgen
und probleme der letzten monate
vielleicht ist es das glück das land und
hansjörg eger zu tränen rührt vielleicht
die erschöpfung
denn auswandern ist anstrengend und
kostet nerven
auswandern machte aber vor allem
glücklich heute können da nicht so ein
kleid dancer mit ihren töchtern lachen
wenn sie sich daran erinnern wie
ungewiss ihr traum von einem besseren
leben in florida einst begonnen hatte
in kanada hat hermann schönbächler mit
seiner familie das paradies gefunden
oder wie er es nennt die ultimative
lebensqualität emma und rolf dobler
waren mit ihren kindern aufgebrochen um
in australien das abenteuer zu suchen
gefunden haben sie eine kleine farm und
das große
[Musik]
du musst nicht gern
sehen auch sie bald auf und davon dann
melden sie sich bei uns für die nächsten
staffeln suchen wir wieder spannende
geschichten von schweizer auswanderern
[Musik]